[Music]
so everyone here in the office has an
Instagram account corridor Instagram
account as well and one of the coolest
things about Instagram are the Instagram
stories and specifically the face
filters that you can apply to your
stories if I just go to my story right
here this is a homemade filter that
someone made and uploaded for everyone
to use for free to access it you just
hit there at the top and it brings up
this little thing here and you can hit
try it and then it automatically loads
it suddenly it work whoa it brows
effects there you have a whole directory
of face filters that you can now search
for browse through and try on your own
to put in your own Instagram stories
it's pretty fun one face culture that's
kind of crazy
it duplicates my face this one's a cool
one
it's like predator with this invisible
active camo I just tap it as with
anything that I find super fun I decided
to look into it a little bit more and
discovered I think I can make one I
think I can make an Instagram face
filter so if you're a follower of this
channel you are definitely familiar of
one thing we like to call Pano's those
bunny squishy based photos you see all
of us posting on Instagram from time to
time they have a really rich history we
accidentally discovered them on a trip
in Japan in 2014 when we were just bored
playing around with the app and we
realized that that pano app if you moved
your heads just so slightly you could
trick it into stitching and squishing
your face or other body parts limbs
anything into these hilarious disfigured
forms it was so so funny and we did it
for years also made a tutorial video as
well if you want to check it out in the
description and so that led us to wait
you know maybe we should make our own
and we started researching it we looked
into it but we came to a brick wall in
our research because it turns out that
the API that governs the panoramic
feature on Apple iPhones basically is
not accessible to developers and so we
gave up got the occasional old-fashioned
piano every once in a while and it kind
of died off until custom Instagram
filters with facial tracking so it turns
out the technology has been on our
phones all along
now Wren has to use his massive cranium
to make us look like we all have massive
craniums so essentially what these face
filters are doing is utilizing this
thing called AR which stands for
augmented reality so here's what I mean
by AR you see how that little square is
tracked my phone has detected that this
is a plane and it is tracking that in
real time and there it goes it fell down
so the AR we're gonna be utilizing is
more of like a face tracking type it's
combination of some advanced hardware
specifically tailored to this but also
some advanced software that's been
written to track your face in real time
there's certain things about our faces
that never change like the distance
between our corners of our eyes the
relationship between our eyes and our
nose and our mouth landmarks of our face
that are very easy to track and
depending on how like these points move
in 3d space the computer or our phones
can tell the orientation of our face and
therefore get a pretty advanced face
track if I want to get into this how do
I get into it well the only thing I know
so far is to use a program called spark
AR it's a program made by Facebook and
think of whatever you will a Facebook
and their privacy concerns they have put
out this face filter program that you
can make your own face filters for free
but I've never actually really worked
with AR before so a friend of mine has
so I've decided to invite him over here
tonight to help me learn this program a
little bit better but first I need to do
my own research so I can kind of prepare
so that when he is here and I can ask
questions I'm not asking them questions
that are super basic back and just
Google search on my own time
[Music]
he's here hey what's up Brian good to
see you good to see you too hey how's it
going it's going well dawn here
he works at DreamWorks I do I'm a
specialist trainer you guys are using
proprietary software that no one else
knows how to use so why teach a lot of
our creative software and tools get
people on boarded and ready to work in a
fully animated studio I found the
perfect person to help me learn how to
use spark a teacher an actual teacher my
hi is when someone learns and then
they're just like oh I'm ready I can I
can go in I can do it I love seeing that
I actually found dawn on Instagram you
have a pretty cool Instagram page you
also made an Instagram filter that
you've published and people can download
and check it out
yes it's called the golden serpent it's
got lights that spin around I'll
definitely show you how to do that and
the lights hit all the normal maps and
get all the bumps and the textures and
the details great I want to make an
effect you know the movie The Hangover
they go to the casino they start trying
to count cards in and black formulas
yeah exactly it's like he goes in this
smart mode and yeah like all the
formulas start popping up around him so
I want to be able to just like write out
a bunch of those formulas on a piece of
paper take an image of that and put a
lot of those images into a filter
floating around my face maybe some are
tracked to my head I can show you
literally how we can do that tonight
great notice there's actually scripting
involved like coding there is how much
of that do you have to do not too much
so far okay because they want to make
this tool accessible as many people as
possible I can tell by how they
structured it it's very programming in
the sense like you're dragging the nodes
around you're seeing that the new
function come out and they have like
little animated lines that go between
them so you can actually see like where
the signals going I love that I wish
Houdini had that we got it
this is basically it we figured out how
to get the emission of the particles
just right no I like I want to get to a
point where I know this program well
enough that I could just start kicking
out all kinds of filters just all the
time I see how fast you learn so this is
going to be happening very soon with you
oh yeah time to keep working on this see
you guys later
well we all know that Ren's out there
working on our Instagram filter but he's
gotten us all probably a little bit more
into them than we should be and I'm
gonna go through some of my favorites
right now and tell you guys about
today's sponsor the ridge
now the ridge is an awesome company that
started on Kickstarter in 2013 with
their most famous product the ridge
wallet Wow look at this one look how
look how pretty I am now they make
wallets backpacks chargers a bunch of
other stuff and basically they turn
these things into tools that make your
life better which I love I'm all about
that stuff so basically I've got a whole
box of wallets right here and I'm gonna
go around and give them to the guys not
only obvious well it's made out of
carbon fiber but they also have a
lifetime warranty 80 years old me like
hey my wallet broke that's right yeah
let's see what you Undine ones
oh I like the green it's kind of that
Hey okay get the ridge wallet did you
know that these wallets have a lifetime
warranty okay
did you know that they have over 30,000
five-star reviews well that sounds like
a good wall right there this one has a
spider on it oh jeez oh there's a spider
on them ten there's a live spider come
with live spiders yes with your wallet
one thing that people love about them is
this very sleek very stylish design
right here where they've got this
durable high quality and that's in
between these two pieces of metal and
you can fit whatever you want into the
wallet right there so go on and put a
card in there and show them what tell
them how to do it dude it comes with a
screwdriver
I've always wanted a screwdriver the
last thing that you guys need to know is
that over five hundred thousand people
already use these wallets so they're
tried-and-true
and they have a lifetime warranty they
also do free worldwide shipping that's
nice mm-hmm that's very considerate yes
so you can get these anywhere in the
world huge thanks to them and remember
go to Ridge wallet dot-com slash
corridor crew use the promo code
corridor crew and you'll get 10% off who
well dude Don's a great guy and we like
problems sobs a bunch of stuff together
and I learned a whole lot about using
spark AR in like literally five minutes
ago we started having our first success
a real time scrunchie faced the way to
go about doing it is you actually
download a 3d model of a face that spark
AR provides for you and using a 3d
program like cinema 4d you can start
moving around those polygons and
distorting them save that out as a 3d
object again and import that into the
program and it'll actually destroy your
face in the same way you distorted that
3d model of a head Clint over here has
just been plugging away even more from
around these things and we have a
real-time scrunchie face and the effect
usually we have really squished simple
heads but here we only are squishing our
face but it's real time I can duplicate
the face tracker and then set the face
to read a second face from now
so now I should just work on both of us
well I mean this is kind of funny I mean
it's pretty close to the scrunchie like
like you can make scrunchies like this
certainly we are so smart now our brain
power is just so high what's really
interesting is that it works really well
through the webcam here this is where
I'm confused because it's working really
fine on the computer but when I send it
to my phone it's not the same effect
there's a very clear difference between
the morphing that's going on here I'm
not exactly sure why because I've only
started learning this program yesterday
our goal is to have this whole thing
basically done this evening / tomorrow
so that we can begin the submission
process that's right there's a whole
submission process for all of this it's
like making an app for the App Store you
have to meet all these guidelines you
have to even make an icon for the face
filter itself which none of these things
are too hard but then it has to go
through a review process and that could
take anywhere between a day or a week so
yeah in the meantime I'm just gonna try
to figure out how to get this working
and that'll be the thing I focus on for
now whoo la - what I realize is over
here there's these two little stick
marks to turn off the eyes and mouth and
suddenly it begins to work so I'm gonna
try this real quick I'm just gonna
export this do my first test right now
now that I've got my working filter and
icon I can actually now go through the
submission process here so what should
we call it
crunch you did it days later hmm
let me show everyone yeah come here me
Dean so you can't see oh my god my bush
dude you're so smart
that's my that's my big brain you know
I'm a true intellectual forehead
wrinkles if you look straight down hey
Nick I can't even look at you working on
up to five different faces at the same
time so how many people can we fit in
the same shot right now say in the
comments they thought that was fake no
that was actually Clinton this is a
monumental occasion here Jake have you
been working out now I want to test how
many people we can get in this shot at
the same time everyone just like line up
around me here is like a family photo oh
my
and it works with the back camera as
well so I can flip this around and just
look at does it work it works it pretty
pretty intense angles it's like doing
weird things with your nose it doesn't I
think it doesn't identify new faces oh
yeah so if you guys are if I'm already
track stay there
[Music]
it's like one-to-one the same the same
exact effect as a scrunchie in video
form - congratulations thank you thank
you this this packs the fun of panoramas
any like an accessible for me yes this
is a pretty big deal because we even met
with a couple of developers and we asked
them if we could build this you guys
think this effect is pretty funny then
you subscribe to the channel
normally I don't subscribe to any
channel but if you guys liked this video
please subscribe and maybe you can learn
how to do this yourself leave a comment
below detailing the next funny face you
think we should make how do I get this
on Instagram so it's really easy all you
gotta do is go to the corner digital
Instagram homepage here just like this
there's a new icon right here in the 3rd
spot it's a smiley face you hit that and
then it brings up all the face filters
we've ever made and this one all you
gotta do is tap it and it brings up the
classic demo that I've already made for
it you just hit try it and boom right
there it's already working but you're
not done yet you gotta hit the icon one
more time and then hit save to camera so
now every time you launch your stories
you can instantly access it right there
so that's all you got to do once you've
downloaded the filter go ahead and post
some of these stories but make sure to
tag court or digital in your Instagram
stories and will actually repost some of
our favorite ones some of the ones that
make us laugh the most will get reposted
for sure so check it out and in the
meantime thanks for watching and thanks
for subscribing and hopefully maybe we
can make more of these filters in the
future so stay tuned and follow Quarter
digital on Instagram
we've got great stuff coming at you